dieser wissenschaftliche durchbruch
sorgt für einige aufregung in gleich
drei studien offenbaren nasa fachleute
die anatomie des roten planeten obwohl
der mars unseren nachbar planet ist war
der blick ins innere des planeten
bislang nicht gelungen es gab nur
vermutungen und die lagen zum teil
ziemlich daneben warum hat der mars ein
magnetfeld verloren und damit
wahrscheinlich auch lebensformen auf ihn
und warum hat er keine plattentektonik
wie ist sein inneres aufgebaut endlich
gibt es auf diese spannende fragen die
ersten antworten und die sind
verblüffend klicks um science and future
erst einmal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen die raumsonde mars
inside lässt tief blicken
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben riesige datenmengen ausgewertet
und enthüllen somit zum ersten mal
überhaupt details zum innenleben des
roten planeten in gleich dreifach
artikeln die im renommierten
wissenschaftsmagazin science
veröffentlicht worden sind geht es um
die anatomie des mars und damit decken
die fachleute einige überraschungen auf
und die sorgen für aufregung nicht nur
in der fachwelt wenn informationen über
das innere unseres nachbarplaneten waren
bislang mangelware und das trotz
intensiver forschung dazu der
geophysiker martin knappmeyer aus berlin
modelle für den aufbau des mars gibt es
seit bald 100 jahren aber hinsichtlich
der abmessung von kruste und kern hat
das seit jahrzehnten kaum fortschritte
gegeben nur die seismologie kann diese
größen direkt messen vorher mussten sie
aus anderen beobachtungen geschätzt
werden jetzt also der durchbruch und zum
ersten mal überhaupt sind die
forschungsteams nun in der lage ganz
konkrete informationen über das
innenleben des roten planeten zu geben
der aufbau des roten planeten
tatsächlich dem aufbau der erde welche
dimensionen hat der mars kern und wie
sieht es aus mit einer plattentektonik
für die fachleute alles andere als
leicht antworten auf diese spannenden
fragen zu finden denn selbst der aufbau
der erde ist immer noch nicht im detail
verstanden also wie funktioniert das bei
fremden weit entfernten planeten im
weltall die wichtigsten facts zu diesem
thema gibt es jetzt bei clixoom science
in future seit november 2008 10 also
seit fast drei jahren ist die raumsonde
insight auf dem mars unterwegs mit an
bord unter anderem ein seismometer das
schockwellen aufzeichnen kann die vom
mars geben und meteoriteneinschlägen
stammen der seismograph seismik
experiment vor in tera structure kurz
ice wurde von der französischen
weltraumbehörde centre national d'etudes
spezial cms gebaut und horst quasi in
den roten planeten hinein um
erschütterungen zu registrieren die
hoffnung der fachwelt dass wir so
endlich den aufbau und die vorgänge im
inneren des roten planeten verstehen
denn die ausbreitung dieser seismischen
wellen lässt rückschlüsse über die
materialien zu aus den kruste mantel und
kern bestehen übrigens gelang es uns
auch damit genau dieser technik den
aufbau des mondes zu verstehen durch die
analyse einiger tausend beben auf dem
mond im zeitraum zwischen 1969 und 1972
konnten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nämlich die einzelnen
schichten des mondes nachvollziehen doch
die herausforderung auf dem roten
planeten ist groß gutem essen können nur
erfolgen wenn das wetter auf dem mars
passt denn dort gibt es wetter die
meiste zeit ist es für das instrument zu
windig und unter diesen umständen können
nur starke beben detektiert werden da es
zu störgeräuschen kommt schon frühere
daten hatten gezeigt dass der rote
planet seismologisch aktiv ist die beben
auf dem mars sind aber schwächer als die
auf der erde kein einziges beten dass in
den vergangenen zwei jahren
aufgezeichnet wurde erreicht die mehr
als eine stärke von 4,0 auf der
richterskala doch mittlerweile sind es
insgesamt rund 700 beben die detektiert
worden waren und all diese konnten jetzt
ausgewertet werden außerdem hat die
insight sonde den mars maulwurf hp 3 mit
am start eine apparatur die sich
eigentlich bis zu fünf meter tief in den
boden hämmern soll um dort temperatur
und wärmeleitfähigkeit des untergrund
materials zu messen so zumindest der
ursprüngliche plan doch der gewünschte
erfolg blieb aus wir hatten hier bei
pixum sunsim future darüber berichtet
denn der mars boden war anders als
erwartet und hp 3 geriet immer wieder
ins stocken anfang des jahres hatte das
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
dann das folgende fazit gezogen wir
haben alles gegeben was möglich war aber
dermaßen stadtpfarrer maulwurf passten
einfach nicht zusammen das dritte
messgerät von insight ist dafür
zuständig die schwankungen der pol achse
des planeten aufzuzeichnen insgesamt ist
inside jetzt schon länger am start als
eigentlich geplant und viele wichtige
daten konnten gesammelt werden
verschiedene forschungsteams haben diese
nun ausgewertet und stellen die
spannenden ergebnisse in gleich drei
studien vor eine wichtige erkenntnis die
die analyse offenbart bezogen auf den
aufbau ist der mars unserer erde
tatsächlich ziemlich ähnlich doch
natürlich gibt es unterschiede und auch
weitere erkenntnisse die die fachwelt
überraschen der mars ist also alles
andere als ein clown der erde auch wenn
er eins genau wie sie blut flüssig waren
dann differenzierte sich sein material
zu schichten doch der genaue aufbau der
schichten aus kernmantel und kruste
unterscheidet sich dennoch von dem
aufbau unseres heimatplaneten unsere
erde kann man sich nämlich bildlich
gesehen vorstellen wie ein pfirsich
aufgebaut als drei schalen ganz außen
eine dünne kruste aus leichtem gestein
beim für sich die haut darunter der
erdmantel der aus schwerem gestein
besteht beim für sich das fruchtfleisch
darunter dann der kern bei der erde
besteht zum großteil aus nickel und
eisen ist das auch beim mars der fall
die messungen der insight mission haben
tatsächlich starke hinweise darauf
geliefert dass der kern des roten
planeten flüssig ist wie die fachleute
jetzt in einer der aktuellen studien
schreiben so scheint es so als sei er
stark mit leichteren elementen wie etwa
schwefel angereichert da der planet
ansonsten insgesamt deutlich
massereicher wäre möglicherweise
befindet sich hier sogar wasserstoff die
analyse der seismischen wellen deckt
zudem auf dass der mars kerntemperatur
von mehr als 1800 grad celsius aufweist
zudem zeigen sich die fachleute von der
größe des mars kerns überrascht so sagt
die berliner planeten wissenschaftlerin
anna katharina bläser der kern des mars
hat nach unseren messungen einen
durchmesser von fast 3700 kilometern das
ist etwa die hälfte des kern durchmesser
der erde und liegt eher am oberen ende
des größten bereichs den alle vorherigen
abschätzungen ergeben hatten eine
weitere spannende erkenntnisse zum
aufbau des mars ist dass es sich dabei
wohl um einen one plate planet handelt
heißt also der rote planet weiß nur eine
einzige kontinentalplatte auf angriff
der unterschied zur erde die ja über
sieben große platten verfügt die in
bewegung sind heißt also auch der mantel
des mars unterscheidet sich von dem der
erde die sogenannte lithosphäre reicht
bis zu 600 kilometer tief in den mars
dass es doppelt so tief wie hier bei uns
auf der erde ist diese bis zu 200
kilometer starke gesteinsschicht teil
der driftenden kontinentalplatten eine
plattentektonik wie bei uns existiert
also auf dem roten planeten
offensichtlich nicht auf die dicke jesus
fähre das maß voll kann flüssiger
heißerer mantelteil doch eine
entsprechung zu unserem unteren
erdmantel fehlt dieser beginnt bei uns
in etwa 660 kilometern tiefe und
zeichnet sich durch feste mineral form
aus diese sind trotz der hitze fest und
zwar bedingt durch den hohen druck
charakteristisch ist das mantel mineral
mit der bezeichnung britt man nicht doch
genau dieses scheint auf dem mars nicht
zu existieren stattdessen dominiert hier
das mineral olivin was das zur folge hat
erklärt der wissenschaftler simon stelle
aus zürich das bedeutet dass dem mars
die relativ dichte und wärme isolierende
schicht des unteren erdmantels fehlt und
genau das könnte auch die erklärung
dafür sein warum der mars ein magnetfeld
verloren hat die fachwelt vermutet dass
sein inneres sehr schnell auskühlt wegen
der fehlenden stabilen und isolierenden
britta nicht ganz anders als bei der
erde offenbart sich auch die kruste des
mars die scheint überraschend dünn zu
sein zudem setzt sich die kruste des
roten planeten aus unterschiedlichem
material zusammen sie ist in zwei oder
sogar drei schichten unterschiedlicher
zusammensetzung unterteilt dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam in jedem fall können
wir jedoch ausschließen dass die ganze
kruste aus dem gleichen material besteht
dass man aus oberflächen messungen und
vermaß meteoriten kennt doch hier sind
noch viele fragen offen und die daten
lassen verschiedene interpretationen zu
klar ist sowieso dass wir trotz dieser
ausführlichen analyse noch längst nicht
alles über unseren nachbarplaneten
wissen dazu heißt es von den fachleuten
selbst wir sind mit der auswertung aller
daten noch lange nicht zu ende der mars
gibt uns noch viele rätsel auf vor allem
die frage ob er sich zur gleichen zeit
und aus demselben material wie unsere
erde gebildet hat offen ist
beispielsweise immer noch warum der mars
eine völlig andere entwicklung
durchlaufen hat als die erde und das
obwohl beide planeten aus den gleichen
ausgangsmaterialien entstanden sind
neuer fund leben auf dem mars immer
wahrscheinlicher anklicken anschauen und
klicks um science and future abonnieren
das geht hier oder über den abo button
unter jedem video das macht schlau und
kostet nichts bis dann bleibt dran